Michael Novak the Jewett chair at the
American Enterprise Institute Washington
DC
it's a two-sided the answer I want to
give that know it Commerce does not
corrupt morals on the contrary it
strengthens moral morals better than the
alternatives in Eastern Europe people
have discovered in the ship from
socialism that a more creative and
dynamic economy requires more of them
requires more more sacrifice more
initiative more foresight harder work
that it makes higher moral demands them
it demands more respect for law and this
is the sort of thing the founders that
anticipated and and wrote about commerce
has a couple other values it's
intimately linked to law it can't
function
you can't send trading ships across the
world to the far side of the world
without contracts ready to be observed
it's too big an expense Congress and law
go together commerce also tends to
strengthen patience the ability to live
with small gains Britain in the 19th
century had on average about a percent
and a half growth a year and that was
the first breakthrough in progress of
what we call modern progress economic
progress and daily wages and daily
welfare increased by something like
sixteen hundred percent and the course
of that hundred years the downside is
that what Lincoln called the Abraham
Lincoln called the silent artillery of
time what early generations sacrifice
for and had visions for and work for and
they work too hard to enjoy much of it
their children try to emulate but their
grandchildren often want to get away
from here different music on the wind
and and and and they prefer not to work
so hard
prefer not to strict alive not so
demanding in life I prefer a more
enjoyable freer life and there there
comes in in the wake of all that very
quickly a kind of decadence in societies
that
a decline in foresight willingness to
work concern about the future rather
than the present and it's what Daniel
Bell calls the cultural contradictions
of capitalism it's very success makes
young people take it all for granted and
be willing to throw it away
treat it too cheaply if this is
localized as I say it's a very small
proportion trouble is mixed in and
derivatives and other bundling effects
of sort of too bright
that is the traders and while Wall
Street you were much too bright for
their own good and for the good of the
country and now it's very hard to locate
where those bad mortgages are they're
bundled in with other things
that's the noxious if this may pass very
quickly it's a terrific investment
opportunity I don't know when the bottom
will be reached but on the way down and
as far down as we've come it's it's
amazing the values that are they'll boy
if people have any cash the great danger
that we face we learned was an
international form of terrorism
non-state not identified with the state
but linked to states that is to say we
didn't have a clear enemy to face there
wasn't any one place to threaten as we
had done in mutual assured destruction
in the getting through the other long
difficult Cold War period and one reason
for that is there's an enormous number
of young males in Arab societies
particularly and in Muslim societies
around the world who have no place to go
for jobs even if they have education as
many of the Bombers of September 11 2001
had master's degrees and in and other
degrees they weren't underprivileged at
all but there were so few opportunities
with him therefore it seemed to me early
on that the best thing that could happen
is if somewhere in the Middle East the
most unsettled part of the world with an
enormous amount of suffering over the
last 50 years almost everybody they are
living under the most
we're not the most extreme but under
extreme forms of tyranny from religious
police as well as security police and a
secret police would be if somehow in
that part of the world the movement got
started toward more commercial republics
those countries have always been good in
commerce but getting commerce free from
the state undirected by the state of the
theocracy and getting the processes of
democratic institutions and above all
the protection of rights going could
result in societies with much more to
offer their young people creative things
to do not a destructive a revolution
bent on tearing down other societies so
that seemed to me to be the really
creative direction to take and there's a
good chance this may come off in Iraq
there's a chance it may not but it was
an opportunity I argued right from the
very beginning that maybe there was a
40% chance of succeeding but 40% was too
high a possibility to waste and we we
had to get the momentum going in a
different direction in that part of the
room
you